the sirens became the soundtrack of a  capital city under attack today below us  as we broadcast ukrainian troops  hurrying for cover  the boxes carry the ammunition with  which they will endeavor to defend this  place when the russians come  [Music]  and then an altogether different sound  the bells ringing out from the golden  domed cathedral named after some michael  appropriately enough the protector of  kiev  and below by the mural we witnessed this  we don't know her name we don't know her  at all but we could guess what she was  praying for  [Music]  it was a moment to remember in an  inexplicable war which with every  passing hour closes in on this city  [Music]  a city where the ak-47 has joined the  phone as the must-have accessory  [Music]  a city where they pray their country and  their freedom can survive whatever the  coming days bring